[Music]
hey everybody
it's monday everybody had a good weekend
is having a good monday so
far pookie's in the background [ __ ]
around
yeah i'm sleepy you're asleep what else
is new
sleep all night and wake up and still be
sleepy yeah
you're just like you should just sleep
all the time hormones [ __ ] it with me
you should go into like cryogenic sleep
like in aliens
sit around i'll wake you up in a few
years eating
sleeping and growing like a lion just
kind of
eat sleep and grow yeah you have to like
do your weights and
take your [ __ ] hormones and eat your
meatloaf yeah that's what we have for
lunch today he made the meat
functions [ __ ] it up the meatloaf that
he made the other day
it was like it was like mount meatloaf
yeah it was like this gigantic like i
didn't see it like he took it out of the
oven to like glaze it or something and i
walked in the kitchen and i was like
holy [ __ ] [ __ ] i froze half of it it
was like this
i was like i got a little carried away
i got a little carried away i think it's
like three pounds of [ __ ] beef or
something no there's a whole bunch of
pounds
oh with more than three pounds of pizza
it was pretty oh yeah a lot more like
seven
seven eight it's good though
yeah it's like seven pounds but we've
had to freeze most of it because like i
said
it's good though it is really good it's
got peppers and onions all in it and
everything and stuff like that we had
mashed potatoes with it yesterday but
today we've seen it yeah put some
apricot
preserves on the top of it yeah that's
my [ __ ] glaze yeah
yeah i like it would just catch up on it
or just plain they're making fun of me
because i call
i said tomorrow was soph's birthday it
is your birthday
birthday with it yeah and mississippi is
just a tea birthday
birthday birthday burt and early day
four throw down says close encounters of
the third meatloaf
i wish i had taken a picture of it
seriously it was like super nice pretty
funny
it was it was it was big and tall
it was just like it was uh twice the
size of a [ __ ]
loaf of white wonder bread it was twice
that he's well
more than twice there's like four loaf
loafs of bread two on the bottom
it was like that yeah yeah it was just
like what i was doing it was like
absurd but like still kind of i had a
dozen eggs in it
yes we'll see that's the thing like
he's gonna make something he's gonna
make a lot of it because then like we
can eat it on it for a few days and then
we can freeze
some of it and then like in a couple and
then like in a couple weeks we're like
hey let's have some meatloaf again
yeah i don't like thawing and refreezing
[ __ ] too much so if i thought
that big old tube of hamburger i'm gonna
try to use all of it yeah
yeah i mean we can't eat that many
hamburgers cook it and then refreeze
some of it i can do that too
yeah so i i approach it with from from
the red
from the restaurant style production
make a bunch of it divide it up freeze
some of it eat the rest of it
binge on it and honestly i can eat the
same thing like every day for a few days
in a row it doesn't bother me yeah two
or three days
as long as as long as it's like [ __ ]
just really good as long as it's
something good
i'm trying to re i'm trying to go back
to it
animal might go back to a carcass
[Laughter]
go back to it eat it later what i mean
especially like when you make indian
food because that's always like
that's better better like the second
third fourth day so it's like i don't
even mind going back and eating the same
thing every day for lunch or whatever
dinner
all right so let's do a brief uh movie
review like we generally do like i said
on the matinee thing because it was
getting to be such a pain to like always
try to find something that came out this
year um i said okay well matt nail would
just be anything that came out like
roughly the past 10 years did you hear
that what damn thunder oh it's thunder
yeah it's getting ready to storm again
but like i said it's florida so that's
what happens
so we actually this was a movie that
came out in 2017
but shutter just added it which it makes
a lot more sense now that
now that i know this is 2017. they
wouldn't make this today
go ahead um yeah this is called mohawk
now
this was actually directed by uh ted
giggin
i think is how you pronounce his last
name even though there's a lot more uh
letters in there than that
now i have actually seen this was his
second movie he's made three and i've
actually
strangely seen all three of them um i'm
gonna say this is probably
my least favorite um of all the ones uh
he also made weir still here which is
the first one
uh that was pretty decent kind of like a
ghost story haunted house type of thing
uh that had barbara crampton in it larry
fessenden
um i liked that one sort of like i don't
think i liked it as much as some other
people did i think just because
the ghosts in it were cool like they
were all burned looking and stuff
but i think he showed them too early and
too much and i vaguely remember it i
don't think you saw it i think i watched
it by myself i thought i saw it with
right with kramden in it i think i saw
it maybe
maybe well she's been in other ones too
she was sh you might have been thinking
of uh
beyond the gates or behind the gates
because she was in that too
um so he made that one first then he
made mohawk and then in 2019 he made
satanic panic which i actually really
liked she's probably like my favorite of
his movies so far as his newest one
um and i think we reviewed it like uh
not too long ago now one thing i didn't
know about this movie was that it was
also
co-written because he co-wrote it but it
was co-written by
with uh the novelist grady hendrix who
i just reviewed one of grady hendricks
grady hendrix's books on my tomes of
terror series
i reviewed horror store um a little
while back which
i really really liked and i also have
another one of his novels uh my best
friend's exorcism which i haven't read
yet but i'm gonna review that one as
well
so apparently how this came about was
that
um ted gagan they were at him and grady
hendrix were actually going to do
satanic panic back in 2015 but then it
got put on hold
and then you know they were like grady
hendricks is like you know i'm really
into like the war of 1812 and you don't
really see a lot of movies like set in
that time period or set around that war
so it's like let's do something like
that so that's kind of where the idea
for this came from so basically this
movie
is set in 1814 and it deals with a
uh a young mohawk woman named oak
which is like short for her i guess her
name is like oguaho or something like
guajo or something like that and um she
basically she has
uh her lover calvin and then she has
another
guy who's like a british officer i think
his name is joshua
and what ends up happening is that
there's been some conflict
like during the war this is kind of like
fairly historically accurate
um you know to the time period and uh
so basically the mohawk are trying to
stay
out of the war of 1812 they're trying to
stay neutral on the whole [ __ ]
um but calvin one of the mohawk
he does not want to stay neutral he
wants to go to war so he basically goes
and raids a uh an american fort
and kills a bunch of uh people while
they're soldiers and stuff while they're
sleeping
uh which obviously causes some conflict
so basically it's like
this is kind of like i don't even know
if i'd call it a horror movie even
although it goes
like it has some supernatural [ __ ] at
the end like it goes into supernatural
direction which i guess isn't too like
much of a spoiler
but it's mostly like a chase thriller so
it's basically like oak and her two male
companions
trying to get away from the dudes that
are chasing them and
you know violence ensues is essentially
like what
happens in the movie so like i said this
is probably my least favorite of his
movies it's not
bad it's okay but
it was just it seemed kind of dull and
it was kind of hard for me to
i didn't really get engaged with the
characters i felt you know what it's
weird i've seen a lot of these actors
like in other of his movies and like
other genre
movies like indie movies and they were
fine
i feel like because this is set during
the war of 1812 i didn't believe
that it was set back then it seemed a
little cheaply made
which is weird because his other two
were not like that
this was it was shot in upstate new york
and it just seemed like it was
i don't know it just it just seemed like
it wasn't up to the same standard as his
other two movies
yeah even though it fell in between them
like i feel like his first one like
looked better than this one just the
visual tone and just totally the movie
was a [ __ ] mess this movie's trash
i mean it just
you know if you're living in the field
you're fighting fighting wars you're
[ __ ] up
everybody's dirty your shit's all worn
[ __ ]
nothing's white everything's [ __ ]
filthy you know what i mean
so nothing everything has a lived in
worn dirty unwashed look the
this they look like they're wearing
costumes you know
yeah you want to learn how to make a
good low budget a western style flick
study the [ __ ] works of clint
eastwood all right
[ __ ] you know uh high plains drifter
you know pale rider josie wales
those were immersive they looked looked
like they were really happening back
then
even the [ __ ] score kind of went
along with the theme that was going on
either a classical
score and you know notes of [ __ ] you
know the 1800s you know banjo or
something
this kind of had you know synthesizer
for dragons yeah it was i think it was a
polish composer that did some of his
other
lit it looked like it was shot in hd
hd settings on a [ __ ] you know tablet
or a phone or so i think maybe what i'm
shocked composition my complaint
is that because i liked his other two
movies like i said his first one we were
still here i didn't love it but it was
like it was good it was a decent movie
satanic panic i really liked um so i
feel like he does okay if like the
setting is like modern
yeah but the fact that they wanted to do
something historical i don't really
think they had the budget to pull it off
and make it look realistic
because like i said i didn't really
believe that the people were from
back then they seemed like modern people
yeah
yeah and they and there's no way you're
gonna buy that these people
are [ __ ] running around in the
wilderness living off the earth and
fighting one another they just
they just look too soft i mean i will
[ __ ] clean
and you know what i mean i mean i will
give him i will give the movie props for
having an actual
mohawk woman playing the role of that so
they didn't have like some other
ethnicity or whatever like
blue eyes though she well she is actual
she is an actual native mohawk though so
they did actually like
you know take pains to like get like the
real thing but it did seem like and i
saw another review of it
blue eyes yeah that's what i mean that
doesn't mean anything she's an indian
princess yeah bonafide yeah we have a
friend that's yeah that's not the same
she's a punk rock girl yeah yeah i
haven't seen her a long time
yeah i was talking to her a couple days
ago but uh oh yeah yeah she said
she's gonna start coming back out oh
okay that's good yeah but yeah so
i mean this like i said it's it's fine i
like
i wish they had like introduced more
supernatural [ __ ] like earlier on
because it seemed like it was a
it was a horror thriller and then i
thought it was over
and then it kind of like so like i said
i'm not going to spoil it or anything if
you want to watch it but um
it's i thought it was over but then like
it keeps going and then like it goes in
like a supernatural direction i wish
they had like
i think there was only one hint that it
was going to go into so like some like a
line that she said that you know implied
that maybe some supernatural [ __ ] would
happen later on
but i kind of wish that they had
threaded it into the story more than it
was because like i said it seemed like
and the movie's not that long it's only
like 91 minutes or something
so it just seemed like it ended but then
like it kept going and then like oh
we're doing supernatural
there's just still just a lot of
problems with the movie i mean it's got
a very
uneven tone the pacing to the edit is
very uneven
script just [ __ ] sucks man i mean
there's just
too many [ __ ] characters there's too
much dialogue there isn't any kind of
central character or theme there's
you can't you know is this third person
is it the first person yeah it goes back
and forth between a lot between the
americans with the british guy and
her and the hurt yeah i'm just you know
we're we're reviewing the movie i just
don't recommend watching it it's a waste
of time it's it's just trash
i mean like i said i don't really like
just saying that outright because some
people
because i've seen some reviews like some
people that really seem to like it
um you know just like some people i saw
some reviews of people that seemed to
like his first movie a lot we are still
here which
i liked but i didn't love it as much as
some people in modern times
to do a western or a period flick
it's expensive yeah you really need to
write it and you got to have the right
[ __ ] soundtrack
you have to you cannot break that
illusion you know what i mean
you have to it has to be immersive and
anything's wrong with it it's easy to
take you out of it
and it takes the audience out of it yeah
i mean yeah like you said
if you like this movie it's because you
don't have any experience with westerns
and period well period piece is just
it's hard to do there's a
that's a certain genre and there are
certain great ones and a lot of shitty
ones
all right and then i was kind of hoping
this would go more in a bone tomahawk
kind of direction
yeah which that was a great period flick
right because it was done right it was
immersive
you actually believed you bought that it
was happening even though it was kurt
russell and that's
kurt russell i mean you know but but you
did like believe
that it was set in that time period yeah
this one i just couldn't
i couldn't break that i think it was
just the way it was shot like
like you said the costumes were kind of
too clean yeah um i just i just
it struck me more as like people
cosplaying
war of 1812 which you know which i can
see because like i said grady hendrix is
like a really
is a history buff and he's really
interested in the war of 1812. so i can
so that's cool that like he wanted to
make a movie that was like set in that
time period because that's
you know a time period that doesn't get
a lot of play in movies
so i feel like wait wait a minute wasn't
ravenous set during the war of 1812
somebody will remind me i haven't seen
that in such a long time that was a
great movie by the way if you haven't
seen that one that came out back in the
90s
but um but it's just i feel like to do
it right you really really really have
to
invest a lot of time you have to have
the budget because if you don't
it's just you're not gonna buy it like i
said i didn't mind like the acting was
fine
um i really liked like uh for for
anybody that's into wwe
wrestling uh the guy playing the
american soldier is the real big guy
that they keep calling the giant
uh that is uh brodie lee jonathan huber
is i guess his real name but he's known
as bernie lilik and wwe
so this is his film debut if you like by
to see that i i actually liked him in
the movie he was like
not comic relief but he was like kind of
a funny guy um
so this this had like some cool [ __ ]
about it like i liked
yeah that's the problem with it is that
every now and then something cool would
come through it
yeah the final act of it with the
supernatural stuff that wasn't bad that
that well
that's what i like that i wish they had
done more with that but it kind of
[ __ ] with you in the [ __ ] first f
15 20 minutes totally it was just all
wrong well a lot of it was just kind of
like running around
in the woods like we're running over
here and we're hiding from them and then
they're running over there
uh the practical effects were good uh
the arrow shots in the throat [ __ ] like
that it was good it looked real
um like one guy had his finger shot off
that looked real it was like you know so
the
the special effects were good um i just
like
like you said i kind of wish they had
gone more in like a whole
supernatural direction with it instead
of just doing
like a chase thriller like for the first
two thirds and then by the way there's
supernatural [ __ ] happening
it's just it didn't that can be pulled
off but it just
i don't think they pulled it off
successfully i detected he was trying to
do
kana what was done in that movie that
had uh
oh [ __ ] what's his name dude to play his
[ __ ]
the pirate um
from pirates of the caribbean oh uh
johnny depp johnny depp did
did a uh a western movie where he was
hanging out with the indians out there
remember that one
yeah yeah yeah it was kind of like a
supernatural thriller i think it might
have had some horror in it too it's been
a long time seen it
that was a very low budget western but
it was really well done
it was i know what you're talking about
but i can't remember the name of it
i know what you're talking about it's
kind of like a it's kind of like an
underground cult classic
i think he was trying to go that way
with it but it didn't work
yeah you have to get the costumes and
the tone right got to use the right
filters on the camera
it's got to look like it was it's got to
look old
everything in it has to look old it has
to feel like it it's transporting you
to another time and really man
it's hard to do that with hd i think
yeah it would probably it's because you
know what i mean
look at look at how what josie wales
looked like i bought
you could buy everything what's
happening in josie where yeah same with
the
high plains drifter you look at it just
everything looks like it's really there
looks like it's actually old it looks
like it's from that period the people
are kind of it's kind of convinced you
that the people
are from that period it's just difficult
to do a period piece
well i mean everything period piece is
always hard to do
all the way around and i will say too
and and this is nothing like no dings on
particular actors or anything
some actors can play characters from a
long time ago
and some can't and like i said it's just
it has to do with their look
it has to do with how they carry
themselves i think one of the things i
know this is going to sound kind of like
out of left field but
i think this is one of the things that
took me out
of as much as i love francis ford
coppola's dracula
i think that was one of the things that
made um keanu reeves
uh stick out so much in that and also in
dangerous liaisons because he was in
that as well
i just keanu reeves is a wonderful
person and he's a really good actor
but i don't i'm he's a modern person i
don't buy him
as a person from the 17th century or as
a person from
you know the time period of dracula like
the 19th century i just don't buy it
and it's nothing to do with his acting
it's nothing to do with that
i don't know what it is it's like some
weird like
it factor that some people can play like
hey i'm from the old west or hey i'm
from like
you know victorian england or something
and some people can't
so it's just i don't know what it is i
just i don't know
but that's just an example so i think
that's kind of what like some of the
people in this were
fine like i bought it from back then but
some of the other actors like i didn't
really believe that they were from that
time period you know what i'm saying
fort drawer down says i wonder if
filmmakers have forgotten how to make
movies like josie wales
wales and uh eastwood's movies know they
were independent films you know he
produced that himself or with
his friends monies so they weren't
really hollywood films
they were indie films and that's one of
the reasons why they were good if they
were hollywood films
it would have to be made by a bunch of
by a committee they'd have to jam a
bunch of product placement in there
they'd have to jam a [ __ ] political
advertising for people that
gave them gave money to the movie so uh
no hollywood can never make a good
western not anymore
why too many white men just too much
racism too much massage you need too
much cruelty to the animals
just anything you know they're gonna
[ __ ] that up you're not going to have a
western move anymore too toxic
toxic masculinity so no you won't have
that
you know they didn't like clint eastwood
they didn't like chinese wood going back
to them
dirty hairy or anything because that was
like they thought they thought they saw
that as nra propaganda so
uh no no hollywood hollywood won't make
that [ __ ]
only indy you're only gonna get that
[ __ ] in indie films
remember we saw clint eastwood in that
movie the mule yeah that was a good
movie
that was a pretty good that was a good
movie he looks like the [ __ ] he looks
like the [ __ ] crypt and
i think that was an indie film too i
think he was involved in making
well he has his own production he's got
his own copy yes i mean he's had his own
production company for ages but i will
say i mean he made like some decent
westerns like even fairly recently but
like unforgiveness of like one [ __ ]
oscar and [ __ ] like that in a fairly
reasonable well yeah it was a while back
but you know what i mean but he but you
know he hasn't
the thing about westerns is that they
come and go like i do feel like
a limited audience you're not going to
make a billion dollar blockbuster so no
they don't want to put a bunch of money
into that
i mean i've seen some decent westerns
like in the past couple but
like i think they were mostly like
independent or they weren't american
you know what i mean the best new
western
i don't know i i showed sophie some
westerns while she was here she had
never seen him she's seen josie whales
then i showed her high plains drifter
which is like that was
that was the crow wild west style i
[ __ ] love high plains drifter
that's probably my favorite one yeah a
lot of people don't realize that that
[ __ ] is a demonic rev
because it's a ghost story from the dead
to [ __ ] wreak vengeance on his towel
and then there's like the sequel to it
in a way was i
it was uh it was um oh what the [ __ ] am
i saying
pale ryder pale ryder was kind of like
an angelic savior
to come save the town so people wanted
wanted high play
like a sequel to high plains drifter you
really can't do that so you had kind of
flipped it and inverted it
so he was kind of like an angelic savior
of the town
but um recently the best
western that i've seen recently would
have been crustles uh
movie yeah which is kind of like which
is kind of like a western
now louis said django unchained uh was
good too i never heard that i haven't
seen it i haven't seen it yet
that's uh yeah that's tarantino right
yeah yeah i've heard that was good a lot
of people seem to like that one but i
haven't seen it yet either
yeah but um yeah you guys haven't seen
you know the [ __ ] uh man with
man with no name trilogy with clint
eastwood you know what is that [ __ ]
you know
uh you know what i'm talking about yeah
you guys know what i'm talking about
well they're classic good the bad the
ugly uh
what was the other ones there's two
other ones [ __ ] they're slipping mine
they're [ __ ] i'm forgetting what they
were called
but everybody says he needs some off
but yeah you need to see those too you
know fistful of dollars louise's full of
dollars yeah
yeah for a few dollars more for a few
dollars more and [ __ ] the good the
bad the ugly that's right sophie said
she loved the 310 to yuma remake that
was actually really good i liked that
and they remade a true grit as well yeah
yeah 310 to yuma had [ __ ] uh what's
his ass from
uh tommy lee jones he was in that right
yeah yeah yeah
uh in general westerns were not
big earners at the [ __ ] box office in
recent times
i mean not since the 60s really the main
audience has
has grown old and died and they're gone
now you know [ __ ]
my dad and granddad's generation they
[ __ ] loved they loved those
they're gone though i mean like i said
you get one that pops up every now and
then it gets like a lot of buzz about it
that a lot of people are really into
but i feel like that's a gen it's kind
of like musicals you know what i mean
it's like i feel like every now and then
a musical comes out nobody flips out
about it but normally
it's not like back in the old days when
like musicals be coming out all the time
and everybody's like woo
new musical you know what i mean it's
kind of like just one of those things
and like i said [ __ ] just goes in cycles
i suppose
but uh yeah so you need to uh you need
to take a nap
i need to take a nap but i was just
thinking about sergio leone
thinking about sergio leone's movie the
best thing about
about that that trilogy that he did was
the [ __ ] music man
yeah the music from good bad and the
ugly and everything in a [ __ ] well
people still remember that [ __ ] nowadays
it was like operatic [ __ ]
post-apocalyptic western
music was it made the film seem so much
more important
you know when you had that that type of
a [ __ ] score behind it
it's hilarious how sometimes um it takes
someone from another culture
the italians to make like a movie that's
like american as [ __ ]
yeah or it's like iconically american
even though it was
made by italians what was what was great
about them though is that they were it
was all southwest so it was merging
mexican
and american culture yeah so it kind of
would work play in
every market it was great you know and
it
had that [ __ ] like a post-apocalyptic
tone to it they kept showing shots of
broken crosses
and crooked [ __ ]
heads you know cemeteries with the
[ __ ] headstones all crooked and
they were kind of spooky it was about
death you know
death and destruction in the end the end
of civilization
and uh dudes out in the desert you know
it looks like they haven't [ __ ]
bathed in [ __ ] months
and that's why you bought into that [ __ ]
well yeah because everybody looks scuzzy
yeah and you didn't really buy into it
with mohawk they looked all freshly
[ __ ]
uh washed and you know they machine
washed [ __ ] clothing and stuff you
know
you know it doesn't work then like i
said that might have been an issue of
like
you know budgetary kind of [ __ ] and then
just kind of like
i don't know it's like i said it doesn't
take much budget to dirty up the
costumes but like you said they
they for real look like costumes they
didn't really yeah they weren't worn out
you know they weren't threadbare
you know [ __ ] in a leone movie people
had clothes that were ripped and then
sewn back together yeah repaired clothes
louis
and all the [ __ ] leather looked real
worn you know everything looked old
yeah like you were using it even the
guns yeah the guns were you know
the varnish gone on parts of the wood
and scratches
and you could tell that you know like
the carbines had been kicked around and
you know dropped on rocks over the years
you know it looked like
something that somebody was really
carrying yeah you know
louie asked if we'd seen the searchers
is that the john wayne movie
no i haven't seen that one i don't think
i've seen that either i mean i might
have seen it because
like i said my grandpa was really really
into westerns and um so i probably saw a
lot of them just like peripherally
because he had him on the tv all the
time
um because i remember seeing like a lot
of john wayne movies and all that kind
of and i had seen like some of the
sergio leone movies and pieces like when
i was younger
but um just because they were always on
because they were into that he loved war
movies and western movies just like all
grandpas everywhere
but yeah all right so uh we're gonna
take a take
off for the day because you need to go
take a nap i gotta take it old man i
just noticed
and somebody like informed me earlier on
youtube and i had just noticed it well
that
uh netflix has just put up the second
season of the new unsolved mysteries
so i know what i'm going to be watching
tonight and if however many of them we
watch we'll review them tomorrow
probably on the matinee i don't know if
we're going to be able to like get
through the whole
season i don't remember how i need to
get at least hours sleep to get my brain
recharged well it's only it's only 3 30
in the afternoon here so you can go and
take a nap
and i will get back to doing what i was
doing and then we'll watch some unsolved
mysteries tonight and then we'll talk
about it tomorrow so that'd be kind of
cool huh
all right so as always thank everybody
for stopping by have a good rest of your
day
and we'll see you guys again tomorrow